From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. It's been such an extraordinary and painful few weeks since the killing of George Floyd. And we have a show today with people in scenes that we recorded this past week, trying to capture what this moment feels like and how different people are reacting and what they're doing.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。乔治·弗洛伊德被杀后的这几周，极其非同寻常且令人痛苦。今天我们的节目记录了本周发生的场景，试图捕捉当下时刻的感受，以及不同的人如何反应和行动。
And I know usually right here at the top of the show, I jump right in with some story. But I think it actually captures what lots of people are feeling this week a lot better to start with this essay from one of our producers, Bim Adewunmi. Here she is.
我知道，节目开头我通常会直接讲故事。但我认为，从我们的制片人之一比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）的这篇文章开始，能更好地捕捉到本周许多人的感受。她来了。
The year I came to live and work in America, 962 people were shot and killed by police across the country. Or maybe the number was 1,093. It depends on who you ask about 2016. One project that counted the dead found that black males aged 15 to 34 were nine times more likely than other Americans to be killed by law enforcement.
我来到美国生活和工作的那一年，全国有962人被警察枪杀。或者数字可能是1093，这取决于你询问的是关于2016年的哪个数据。一个统计死亡人数的项目发现，15至34岁的黑人男性被执法人员杀害的可能性是其他美国人的九倍。
In case you've become fuzzy on timelines, Michael Brown was shot by police in Ferguson, Missouri in 2014. Walter Scott was shot in the back by police in Charleston, South Carolina in 2015. In 2016, Alton Sterling was killed by police in Baton Rouge, Louisiana. And a day later, in Falcon Heights, Minnesota, police shot and killed Philando Castile, while he was in his car with his partner and her 4-year-old daughter.
如果你对时间线有些模糊，迈克尔·布朗（Michael Brown）于2014年在密苏里州弗格森被警察枪杀。沃尔特·斯科特（Walter Scott）于2015年在南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿被警察从背后枪杀。2016年，奥尔顿·斯特林（Alton Sterling）在路易斯安那州巴吞鲁日被警察杀害。一天后，在明尼苏达州猎鹰高地，警察在菲兰多·卡斯蒂利亚（Philando Castile）与伴侣及其4岁女儿坐在车里时，将其枪杀。
Those last two incidents were recorded. Both were viewed by the public at large. At the time Sterling and Castile were killed in 2016, I'd been living in New York for four months. I'd come to America to report on the presidential election campaigns with a wry British eye. I no longer have the original text of my visa application, but I remember distinctly that it mentioned both the 19th century French social scientist Alexis de Tocqueville and the late British journalist Alistair Cooke.
后两起事件都被录像了，且都被公众广泛观看。2016年斯特林和卡斯蒂利亚被杀时，我在纽约住了四个月。我来美国是为了以一种英国人讽刺的眼光报道总统竞选活动。我不记得签证申请的原始文本了，但我清楚记得提到了19世纪法国社会学家亚历克西·德·托克维尔（Alexis de Tocqueville）和已故英国记者阿里斯泰尔·库克（Alistair Cooke）。
Both Alexis and Alistair were men of letters, operating in very different eras of American upheaval. The aim of their writing was to help readers back home understand the unique American situation. They were good names to put on a visa application. It indicated I knew my literary lineage.
亚历克西和阿里斯泰尔都是文人，活跃在不同时代的美国动荡中。他们写作的目的是帮助家乡的读者理解独特的美国局势。在签证申请上写上这两个名字是很好的。这表明我了解自己的文学血统。
But the reality is that beyond the common ground of our jobs, I wasn't really like Alexis or Alistair and moved through the world differently. I was a woman. I was a Muslim. I was a child of working class immigrants, born to parents who themselves were born in an African country still under the yoke of the English monarchy. And of course, I was black. I still am.
但现实是，除了工作上的共同点，我并不像亚历克西或阿里斯泰尔那样，我在世界中的行走方式也不同。我是女性，我是穆斯林，我是工人阶级移民的孩子，父母出生在一个仍处于英国君主制枷锁下的非洲国家。当然，我是黑人。我依然是。
Thanks to the spread of empire, I'm no stranger to the project of colonization. Of all the things I would be reporting on and experiencing firsthand in America, the subject of blackness was the thing with which I had the most literal, most lived experience. British police have historically not used guns like their American counterparts.
多亏了帝国的扩张，我对殖民计划并不陌生。在我将在美国报道和亲身体验的所有事物中，关于黑人身份的话题是我有着最直接、最深刻生活经验的。历史上，英国警察不像他们的美国同行那样使用枪支。
But the history of disproportionate black deaths during and after interactions with police in the UK tells a familiar story. The lyrics are different, but the melody is old and known to me. That's the horrible thing about this moment. I've been here before.
但英国在与警察互动期间及之后黑人死亡比例过高的历史，讲述了一个熟悉的故事。歌词不同，但旋律很老，是我所熟知的。这就是这一刻最可怕的地方。我以前来过这里。
And so when George Floyd was killed in Minneapolis on Memorial Day in the last week of May, I had a feeling of resigned deja vu. Police had arrested a man, and then, less than a half hour later, that man was dead. The manner of it-- a cop's knee pressing down on his neck for eight minutes and 46 seconds-- felt like a stage play we'd all seen before. The fact that it had been recorded felt proper, like a sort of sacred practice.
因此，当乔治·弗洛伊德在5月的最后一周阵亡将士纪念日于明尼阿波利斯被杀时，我有一种无奈的似曾相识感。警察逮捕了一个人，不到半小时后，那个人就死了。那种方式——警察的膝盖压在他的脖子上8分46秒——感觉就像我们都看过的一出戏。它被录像的事实感觉很恰当，像是一种神圣的仪式。
The mundane location of it was familiar, too-- a regular street suddenly transformed into an arena for public death. The echo of some of Floyd's dying words eerily the same as Eric Garner's in 2014-- I can't breathe. Even that felt like an on-the-nose rerun of a series called, How to Die in America.
它发生的世俗地点也很熟悉——一条普通的街道突然变成了公共死亡的竞技场。弗洛伊德临终前的一些话与2014年埃里克·加纳（Eric Garner）的遗言诡异地相似——“我无法呼吸”。即使这感觉也像是名为《如何在美死亡》系列剧的一场直白的重播。
Almost every element of what happened next hit the exact beat it was supposed to. The video of his life being snuffed out went viral. Tabloid newspapers brought up his criminal past. Protests began the day after he was killed. Against police brutality, yes, but also against the organizing principle of colonialism in general, and explicitly against the ideology of white supremacy itself.
接下来发生的事情几乎每个环节都完全符合预期的节奏。他生命被终结的视频疯传。小报提到了他的犯罪记录。抗议活动在他被杀后的第二天就开始了。针对警察暴行，是的，但也针对殖民主义的组织原则，并明确针对白人至上主义的意识形态本身。
And it wasn't just black people yelling. Things shifted. Something was different. By the end of the week, there were protests across the country-- all 50 states. And a week after that, there had been protests in other countries, too. Last weekend, I watched protesters in the west of England topple the statue of Edward Colston, a Bristol man who made his fortune by trading in thousands of enslaved Africans.
不只是黑人在大喊大叫。情况变了。有什么东西不同了。到周末结束时，全国50个州都出现了抗议活动。一周后，其他国家也出现了抗议活动。上周末，我看着英国西部的抗议者推翻了爱德华·科尔斯顿（Edward Colston）的雕像，这位布里斯托尔男子通过交易数以千计的被奴役非洲人发了财。
After kneeling on the supine statue's neck, protesters rolled it down the street, before tipping it into the Bristol Harbour. My London friends sent me videos and photos of protests they had attended, while doing their best to maintain social distancing. As someone on Twitter put it, I can't believe corona blew a 28-3 lead to racism.
抗议者跪在雕像仰卧的脖子上后，将其沿街滚动，然后推入布里斯托尔港。我在伦敦的朋友给我发了他们参加抗议活动的视频和照片，同时尽力保持社交距离。正如推特上有人所说，我不敢相信新冠病毒在领先28比3的情况下输给了种族主义。
The day after George Floyd was killed, I quit Twitter because of my propensity for doom scrolling. I knew my right thumb would be in constant, endless motion, eating up breaking news that would later crystallize into insomnia and migraines.
乔治·弗洛伊德被杀的第二天，因为我有不停刷屏阅读负面新闻的倾向，我删除了推特。我知道我的右手拇指会处于持续、无休止的运动中，消耗那些后来会演变成失眠和偏头痛的突发新闻。
But even on Instagram, it was a wall of George Floyd content. Suddenly, I was overwhelmed with graphics and photos and links to bail funds and that uniquely American habit-- crowdfunding. On pastel-colored digital easels, people wrote anti-racist quotes from Angela Davis and Ijeoma Oluo.
但即使在Instagram上，这也是一面乔治·弗洛伊德内容的墙。突然间，我被各种图片、照片、保释基金链接以及那种独特的美国习惯——众筹——淹没了。在柔和色调的数字画架上，人们写着安吉拉·戴维斯（Angela Davis）和伊乔玛·奥卢奥（Ijeoma Oluo）的反种族主义引语。
Artists created tributes to people like 26-year-old Breonna Taylor, who was killed in her own home in Louisville, Kentucky back in March, and Tony McDade, a trans man killed in Tallahassee.
艺术家们为像26岁的布里安娜·泰勒（Breonna Taylor）这样的人创作了悼念作品，她于3月在肯塔基州路易斯维尔的家中被杀，还有在塔拉哈西被杀的跨性别男子托尼·麦克戴德（Tony McDade）。
There were guides on everything, from how to dress and prepare for a protest in the age of coronavirus to the specifics of raising truly anti-racist children. My favorite-- or least favorite-- genre of these is the one that teaches non-black people how to be people in this moment.
到处都有指导指南，从如何在冠状病毒时代为抗议活动穿衣和准备，到如何培养真正的反种族主义子女的具体细节。我最喜欢——或者说最不喜欢——的一类，就是那些教非黑人如何在这个时刻表现得像个人的指南。
Posts with headings like, "Here's what to say to your black friends," or, "Check in on your black friends," were seemingly everywhere. After that first weekend of protests, I got a text in one of my group chats from a black friend. "Have either of you gotten texts from white people this weekend," she wrote. "Yes," we both replied. We all shared a dark laugh.
标题如“以下是对你的黑人朋友该说的话”或“询问你的黑人朋友”的帖子似乎随处可见。那第一个抗议周末过后，我收到一位黑人朋友在群聊中发来的信息。“你们俩这个周末收到白人的短信了吗？”她写道。“收到了，”我们都回复了。我们都发出了一种苦涩的笑声。
Black people have been dying in America and elsewhere for so long. What's so different about now? That first weekend, I kept asking myself this. What's making white people care now? I keep looking to see what I've missed. What was the thing that's making brands draw these lines now?
黑人在美国和其他地方被杀已经太久了。现在有什么不同？那个周末，我一直在问自己这个问题。是什么让白人现在开始关心了？我一直在看我错过了什么。到底是什么让各大品牌现在开始划清界限？
What makes babynames.com dedicate its landing page to listing black victims of police violence, along with the note, "Each one of these names was somebody's baby. Babynames.com stands in solidarity with the black community."
是什么让Babynames.com将其主页专门用于列出被警察暴行伤害的黑人受害者，并附注：“每一个名字都曾是某个人的宝贝。Babynames.com与黑人社区团结一致。”
What is compelling people, a lot of them white, to stand up for the first time and proclaim that it's time to do something? How is it that I have read more proposals for defunding and abolishing the police in the last two weeks than over the course of the last two years? What's making people in small towns across America, from Lewistown, Montana to Bad Axe, Michigan, get up and protest now?
是什么促使人们，其中许多是白人，第一次站出来宣称是时候采取行动了？为什么我在过去两周里读到的关于削减和废除警察的提案，比过去两年还要多？是什么让美国各地小城镇的人们，从蒙大拿州的刘易斯敦到密歇根州的巴德阿克斯，现在都站出来抗议？
If Sandra Bland didn't do it, if Eric Garner didn't do it, if Atatiana Jefferson didn't do it, if Aiyana Stanley-Jones didn't do it, how is the death of George Floyd the thing that moves the needle? I can't think of an easy answer.
如果桑德拉·布兰德（Sandra Bland）没能做到，如果埃里克·加纳没能做到，如果阿塔蒂亚娜·杰斐逊（Atatiana Jefferson）没能做到，如果艾雅娜·斯坦利-琼斯（Aiyana Stanley-Jones）没能做到，乔治·弗洛伊德的死怎么就成了改变现状的转折点？我想不出简单的答案。
It's not because he was seven years old, like Aiyana Stanley-Jones was. It's not because he was a 12-year-old boy, like Tamir Rice was. It's not because he was an award-winning EMT who tweeted that 2020 would be her year, like Breonna Taylor was.
不是因为他像艾雅娜·斯坦利-琼斯那样只有七岁。不是因为他像塔米尔·赖斯（Tamir Rice）那样是个12岁男孩。不是因为他像布里安娜·泰勒那样是个在推特上说2020年将是她的一年的获奖急救员。
So the next likely answer is that it's as simple as the effect of accumulation. Finally, there are enough dirty clothes in the hamper to justify putting on a load of laundry. Maybe the increased visibility of the stark differences between the haves and have-nots over the last few years has produced a populace ready to be pushed into the hitherto radical lane of thought that suggests, actually, black lives do matter. Maybe the activists finally broke through. Who can say?
所以下一个可能的答案就是，这就像积累效应一样简单。篮子里的脏衣服终于多到足以证明洗衣服是合理的了。也许过去几年里富人和穷人之间鲜明对比的日益可见，已经培养出了一个准备好被推入迄今为止激进思想轨道的群体，这个想法认为：实际上，黑人的生命确实很重要。也许活动人士终于取得了突破。谁能说得准呢？
A part of me wants white people at large to feel deeply ashamed. This is entry level. Stop killing us. This is basic. If the killing of George Floyd could unleash this tidal wave of demonstration, what was stopping you before? He's as meaningful as any other victim of police violence, named or unnamed here today. You could have harnessed all this energy 15, 20, 200, 500, 1,000 deaths ago. But that didn't happen.
我的一部分想要广大的白人感到深深的羞耻。这只是入门级别。别再杀我们了。这很基本。如果乔治·弗洛伊德的被杀能引发这场抗议的海啸，以前是什么阻止了你们？他像今天这里被提及或未被提及的任何其他警察暴力受害者一样有意义。你们本可以在15、20、200、500、1000起死亡事件之前就利用这些能量。但这并没有发生。
And so when I ask the question, why now, the truth is that I don't really care. All these white people newly attuned to this frequency the rest of us know so well. I told a friend that I wanted everyone to do their belated learning far away from me.
所以当我问为什么是现在这个问题时，真相是我并不真的在乎。所有这些刚对这个我们其他人如此熟悉的频率产生共鸣的白人。我告诉一位朋友，我希望每个人都在离我很远的地方补上这迟来的课程。
I don't want to see how anyone is carrying the one. I don't want to teach anyone. I have no office hours. I don't want to know what triggered your come to Jesus moment. I have no interest in seeing how the sausage gets made. I just want to rock up to the table and enjoy my breakfast.
我不想看到任何人如何进行所谓的“进位加法”。我不想教任何人。我没有办公时间。我没兴趣知道是什么触动了你们的“顿悟时刻”。我没兴趣看香肠是怎么制作的。我只想坐到餐桌旁，享受我的早餐。
I know what's different for me. I'm angrier now. I think of what parents say about how their hearts grow bigger after a second child, instead of having to share the love they already feel. That's me. But instead of love, it's rage. I find that this time, I am furious. That's what's different.
我知道对我来说有什么不同。我现在更生气了。我想起父母们说第二个孩子出生后心胸如何变得更宽广，而不是分享他们已有的爱。我是那样。但取代爱的不是爱，而是愤怒。我发现这次，我非常愤怒。这就是不同之处。
Bim Adewunmi is one of the producers of our show.
比姆·阿德温米是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "BREATHING WHILE BLACK" BY MONONEON]
[音乐 - Mononeon的《Breathing While Black》]
Act Two, Before Sunrise. So one night, recently, one of our producers, Diane Wu, stopped by Mr. Mango, which is a corner grocery in New York City. It's two or three blocks from the Barclays Center, where lots of the big New York City protests have happened. And it's just down the street from Brooklyn Hospital, which has been hard hit treating coronavirus patients in these last few months-- New York, of course, the epicenter of coronavirus cases in this country.
第二幕，日出之前。最近的一个晚上，我们的制片人戴安·吴（Diane Wu）路过纽约市的一家角落杂货店“芒果先生”（Mr. Mango）。离巴克莱中心只有两三个街区，那里发生了很多大型纽约抗议活动。离布鲁克林医院也很近，过去几个月那里在救治冠状病毒患者方面遭受重创——纽约当然是这个国家新冠病毒病例的震中。
Mr. Mango is a 24-hour grocery store that has stayed open through the city's shutdown, through the curfew. It is an intersection that all kinds of people pass through. And that particular night that Diane was there, protesters were singing "Happy Birthday" to Breonna Taylor at a little plaza across the street. A woman in scrubs at the store was FaceTiming somebody about onions. Cop cars pulled up.
芒果先生是一家24小时营业的杂货店，在城市封锁和宵禁期间一直保持营业。这是一个各色人等都会经过的交叉路口。戴安在那里的那个晚上，抗议者在街对面的一个小广场上为布里安娜·泰勒唱着“生日快乐”。店里的一位穿着刷手服的女性正在和某人FaceTime谈论洋葱。警车停了下来。
And standing there, watching all of this, during this intense moment we're all living through, where race and justice and survival are at the forefront of everything, Diane wondered what were all these different people thinking in this quiet little grocery store.
站在那里，看着这一切，在这个我们所有人都在经历的紧张时刻，种族、正义和生存成为了一切问题的重中之重，戴安好奇在这个安静的小杂货店里，这些形形色色的人在想什么。
So she went back the next night-- it was this past Saturday night, June 6-- with a microphone and with our co-worker, Lina Misitzis. They stayed all night, until 5:00 in the morning, talked to dozens of people. And they put this next story together.
所以第二天晚上——也就是上周六晚上，6月6日——她带着麦克风和我们的同事莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）又去了。他们待了一整晚，直到凌晨5点，和几十个人聊了天。然后他们整理出了这个接下来的故事。
Usually, I just want to say, we do not point out the race of the people that we talk to on the radio, unless there's some particular reason. But race is the context for so many interactions, including the ones at the store, that in this story, we're going to identify the race or nationality of everybody who you're going to hear. OK, here's Diane.
通常，我想说的是，除非有特殊原因，否则我们不会在广播中指出谈话对象种族。但在商店里的互动中，种族是如此多互动的情境，所以在这个故事中，我们将指出所有你将听到的对象种族或国籍。好的，听听戴安的。
We got to Mr. Mango just before the city's 8:00 PM curfew. Inside, it was crowded and serious. People were shopping silently, trying to keep a distance, trying to move fast and get out of the store and get home by 8:00. A police helicopter buzzed overhead.
我们在城市晚上8点宵禁前赶到了芒果先生。里面人很多，神情严肃。人们默默地购物，试图保持距离，试图快速行动，赶在8点前回家。一架警用直升机在头顶盘旋。
Mr. Mango is a small grocery store with inexpensive produce out front and a mix of regular and bougie groceries inside. They have 35 kinds of honey, but also dollar pineapples. The cashiers were hurriedly checking everyone out from an island in the middle of the store.
芒果先生是一家小型杂货店，店外有廉价农产品，店内混合了普通杂货和高端杂货。他们有35种蜂蜜，但也有一美元的菠萝。收银员在商店中间的一个岛台上匆忙地结账。
Once curfew kicked in, things relaxed. Like, all the anxious rule followers had cleared out. The regulars started filtering in-- neighborhood people, essential workers. A white guy in pajama pants came in to buy a corkscrew. Chan, who's Thai and manages the restaurant three doors down, he came in after his shift ended at 10:00 to pick up some pita chips for his husband. The curfew had actually been good for business.
宵禁一过，气氛就放松了。那些焦虑的守规矩的人都离开了。常客们开始涌入——邻里居民、必要工种人员。一个穿着睡裤的白人进来买开瓶器。陈（Chan）是泰国人，管理着三扇门外的那家餐厅，他在10点下班后进来为丈夫买些皮塔薯片。宵禁实际上对生意有好处。
When it's next to 8:00, people were so afraid that they will have to stuck at home or something, so a lot of delivery is going to happen around that time, yeah.
接近8点时，人们非常害怕被困在家里之类的事情，所以那时候有很多外卖订单，是的。
How many tonight?
今晚有多少？
Tonight, we hit, like, 3,000.
今晚，我们达到了大约3000。
$3,000, which is 50% more than usual, he told me. Devon, a black man who lives around the corner, stopped by in a camo facemask to pick up some ice and cups. He was hanging out with a friend from Jersey that night.
3000美元，比平时多了50%，他告诉我。德文（Devon）是一位住在拐角处的黑人，戴着迷彩口罩路过这里买冰块和杯子。那天晚上他正和一位来自新泽西的朋友一起玩。
Yeah, with all this going on, I need something to unwind a little bit. But this has been rough, this world right now-- everything that's going on. No basketball season, no sports. My daughter can't graduate high school. Couldn't have a graduation. Only great thing about this thing, my grandson is born now.
是啊，发生这一切，我需要放松一下。但现在这世道真是艰难——发生的一切。没有篮球赛季，没有体育运动。我女儿不能高中毕业了。没法举行毕业典礼。这件事唯一伟大的事是，我孙子出生了。
Wow, congratulations.
哇，恭喜你。
One month old. I'm sorry for people who lost death, but my daughter's happy. My grandson is home. They're safe.
才一个月大。我为那些失去亲人的人感到难过，但我女儿很高兴。我孙子回家了。他们很安全。
The ice he was carrying to the register, actually, was for a toast for baby Thurmond. One group of regulars was hard to get to talk, because they were either rushing to work or exhausted-- the hospital workers. Everyone else had moved on to the new crisis, but they were still very much inside the previous one.
其实他拿着去收银台的冰块是为庆祝瑟蒙德宝宝（Baby Thurmond）干杯用的。有一群常客很难开口交谈，因为他们要么急着上班，要么筋疲力尽——那是医院工作人员。其他人都已经转向了新的危机，但他们仍然深陷之前的危机中。
Do you have a minute to talk?
你有时间谈谈吗？
Mm, I just came from work. [INAUDIBLE]
嗯，我刚下班。（无法听清）
A black woman on the hospital cleaning crew, Bernice, talked to me for one minute and 24 seconds while she shopped, and wasted none of it.
医院清洁工伯尼斯（Bernice）是一位黑人女性，在购物时和我聊了1分24秒，一秒都没浪费。
I'm tired.
我很累。
Yeah.
是啊。
Because of this coronavirus, I've been working for the last 96 days. And then you got these people out here protesting, which I'm all for that, but they're going about the wrong way with the burning buildings and stores. And people got to survive, you know. This is your neighborhood. You shouldn't be doing stuff like that. You know, you've got to do it the right way. But that's just my opinion. And I'm delirious and I'm tired right now, so I'm about to go.
因为这种冠状病毒，我已经连续工作了96天了。然后你有这些人在外面抗议，我全力支持，但他们的方式不对，烧毁建筑物和商店。人们得生存，你知道吗。这是你的社区。你不应该做那种事。你知道，你必须用正确的方式去做。但那只是我的意见。我现在神志不清，很累，所以我要走了。
I know. I feel tired for you-- 96 days.
我知道。我为你感到疲惫——96天。
I'm actually walking slowly by slowly, taking it step by step. I am, like, burnt out, drained. I don't know what to say anymore. Just go to work and just pray that the same way you leave there, you come back home that way. That's all I can say, mama. You be careful. Have a good night. I gots to go.
我实际上是慢慢地走，一步一步来。我好像烧坏了，被掏空了。我不知道还能说什么。只是去工作，祈祷像你离开家一样，平安回到家。我只能说这些，妈妈。你保重。祝你有美好的一晚。我得走了。
At the cashier's island, there's Ronny, who's new at Mr. Mango. He just started working here this week. He's Latino, from Guatemala. And Dorje, the longtime overnight cashier, gracious and calm. Dorje is from Bhutan. He's the quiet center of gravity of the whole store and does not want to be on the radio. Every time I swing the microphone in his direction, he leans back and puts his hands up to protect himself from it.
在收银台岛，有罗尼（Ronny），他刚来芒果先生不久。他这周才开始在这里工作。他是拉丁裔，来自危地马拉。还有多吉（Dorje），那是长期的夜班收银员，亲切且冷静。多吉来自不丹。他是整个商店安静的重心，不想上广播。每次我把麦克风伸向他，他就往后仰，举起手保护自己。
Once the mic is safely out of sight, though, he's happy to talk. After I interview any of his regulars, Dorje helpfully fills in the details. That guy is a really hard worker. They come almost every day after a long day. They used to buy Corona, but after coronavirus, they started getting a different beer.
不过一旦麦克风安全地离开视线，他就乐于交谈了。在我采访他的任何常客后，多吉都会很有帮助地补充细节。那个家伙是个非常努力的工人。他们几乎每天在漫长的一天结束后都会来。他们过去常买科罗娜啤酒，但在冠状病毒之后，他们开始买另一种啤酒。
One of the regulars, Schecter, who's Asian, tells me that Mr. Mango is his favorite store in his whole life. And the reason is Dorje and the other night cashier, Karma, who's off tonight.
常客之一谢克特（Schecter），亚裔，告诉我芒果先生是他一生中最喜欢的商店。原因就是多吉和另一位今晚休息的夜班收银员卡玛（Karma）。
Last year, I had a bad year. Everything started to fall apart. In my worst moments, I would come here at midnight or 1:00 in the morning and just be with them. And I found out that I wasn't the only one.
去年，我过得很糟糕。一切都开始分崩离析。在我最糟糕的时刻，我会在午夜或凌晨1点来这里和他们待在一起。我发现我不是唯一一个这样的人。
Ever since the pandemic, Dorje has been working more-- 72 hours a week. He's tired. Tomorrow is his day off. As it gets later, around midnight, the mood at Mr. Mango shifts. Some of the energy outside filters in. Lina tells what happens next.
自大流行以来，多吉工作的时间更多了——每周72小时。他很累。明天是他休息日。随着时间流逝，到了午夜左右，芒果先生的气氛变了。外面的一些情绪渗透了进来。莉娜讲述了接下来的事情。
Protesters keep turning up. A sunburned couple, white, holding hands on their way home from a rally. They buy ice cream, beer, and lemons. Patrick, an older black man with long hair and a beard to match, he'd been out protesting, too. Wanted to grab a snack before turning in. He bought one pineapple.
抗议者不断涌现。一对晒黑的夫妇，白人，手拉手从集会上走回家。他们买了冰淇淋、啤酒和柠檬。帕特里克（Patrick），一位留着长发和胡须的年长黑人，也去抗议了。想在睡觉前吃点零食。他买了一个菠萝。
And then these protesters-- I call them Josh and Katie. They seemed about 30, both of them white. She had long red hair, and he had knuckle tattoos, but he refused to show them to us-- for his own protection, he said, and because he didn't want to put himself as an individual ahead of the movement.
然后是这些抗议者——我称他们为乔什（Josh）和凯蒂（Katie）。他们看起来大约30岁，都是白人。她留着红长发，他有指关节纹身，但他拒绝向我们展示——他说为了他自己的保护，也因为他不想把自己作为一个个体置于运动之前。
Do you like persimmons?
你喜欢柿子吗？
Not really.
不太喜欢。
Why not? So tell me, what's up?
为什么不呢？告诉我，怎么了？
I just don't like them that much. I don't know why. I never really liked them that much.
我只是不太喜欢它们。我不知道为什么。我从来不太喜欢它们。
You're getting started.
你才刚开始。
But I like them. You know I eat anything.
但我喜欢它们。你知道我什么都吃。
Josh and Katie told Diane they'd spent the day marching all over Brooklyn.
乔什和凯蒂告诉戴安，他们花了一天时间在布鲁克林各处游行。
Went through Flatbush, Crown Heights, Bedstuy, and then back up here to Barclays.
穿过弗拉特布什（Flatbush）、皇冠高地（Crown Heights）、贝德斯图（Bedstuy），然后回到巴克莱中心。
You sound a little tired.
听起来你有点累。
I was locked up for a long time after one of the recent violent assaults on a protest in one of the outer boroughs.
在最近一次外围行政区的暴力袭击抗议事件后，我被关了很久。
So you got arrested this week.
所以你这周被捕了。
Yeah.
是的。
Josh kept talking about what he called movement moments. Katie focused on shopping for fruit.
乔什一直在谈论他所谓的运动时刻。凯蒂专注于购买水果。
They have the best fruit. They have plantains. They have litchis. They have soursop. They have star fruit. They have mamey. They have things you don't see in America. I mean, you know, these guys are the real deal.
他们有最好的水果。他们有大蕉。他们有荔枝。他们有番荔枝。他们有杨桃。他们有你在美国看不到的东西。我是说，你知道，这些家伙才是真正的行家。
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
噢，噢，噢，噢。
Hang on.
等一下。
What's going on?
怎么了？
发生了什么？
Hey, what's up? How're you doing?
嘿，怎么了？你好吗？
What just happened?
刚才发生了什么？
What happened was a couple NYPD walked into Mr. Mango, and Josh and Katie immediately reacted. Josh very dramatically stopped talking, wrapped a scarf around his face, so that all that were showing were his eyes. He looked like a mummy, who was also an anarchist. He crept away, picked up some tofu, and held it like a prop and glanced back at the police. Meanwhile, I went and talked to the officers, one white, the other Dominican.
发生的是两个纽约警察走进了芒果先生，乔什和凯蒂立即反应过来。乔什非常戏剧性地停止了说话，用围巾裹住脸，只露出眼睛。他看起来像个木乃伊，也是个无政府主义者。他悄悄走开，拿起一些豆腐，像道具一样拿着，瞥了一眼警察。与此同时，我去和警察谈了话，一个白人，另一个是多米尼加人。
What are you guys here for?
你们来这里是为了什么？
Just buying snacks.
只是买点零食。
Snacks and water.
零食和水。
I got water and pretzels.
我买了水和椒盐卷饼。
I got some water.
我买了一些水。
While I was talking to the police, Josh and Katie moved to the back of the store, where they accidentally knocked over some toilet paper. The whole thing is pretty conspicuous. But they didn't want to be near the NYPD, which the cops definitely noticed, but they didn't care.
当我和警察说话时，乔什和凯蒂移到了商店后面，不小心碰倒了一些卫生纸。整件事非常显眼。但他们不想靠近纽约警察，警察肯定注意到了，但他们不在乎。
It doesn't bother me at all.
这对我一点影响都没有。
Wait, because you're used to it?
等等，是因为你习惯了吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
But sometimes we get appreciation, too, you know?
但有时我们也会得到赞赏，你知道吗？
It goes both ways.
这不仅仅是一方面的。
We get both, you know?
我们都会收到，你知道吗？
Both ways, yeah.
双方都有，是的。
Did you get appreciation today?
你今天得到赞赏了吗？
Um--
嗯——
No.
没有。
That no was coming from Josh. He's listening to our conversation. Officer Rodriguez heard him, rolled his eyes.
那个“没有”来自乔什。他在听我们的谈话。罗德里格斯（Rodriguez）警官听到了，翻了个白眼。
Yeah, but that's the same guy that when he's getting robbed or something, he's going to call 911. And he's going to expect us to show up. You get what I'm saying? So.
是的，但这就是同一个人，当他被抢劫之类的时，他会打911。并且他会期待我们出现。你明白我的意思吗？所以。
The officers pay for their water and pretzels, tell me they have to get back to work. They're on patrol duty. I walk out with them, and when I get back, Josh has uncovered his face. He's talking about Standing Rock.
警察付了水和椒盐卷饼的钱，告诉我他们必须回去工作。他们在巡逻。我和他们一起走出去，当我回来时，乔什已经摘下了脸上的遮盖物。他在谈论立岩（Standing Rock）。
When you've seen him shoot down Americans and natives at Standing Rock with four different jurisdictions at once in every brutal way they can--
当你亲眼看到他们在立岩用四种不同的管辖权同时以他们能想到的所有残暴方式射杀美国人和原住民时——
Wait, can I tell you what he said about you?
等等，我能告诉你他说了你什么吗？
What did he say?
他说了什么？
I asked if it upset him that you wouldn't step up to pay until he was gone, and he said no, but when he gots robbed, he's going to call 911 and expect us to help him.
我问他，当你不在时他才付钱是否让他感到不安，他说不，但当他被抢劫时，他会打911并期望我们去帮他。
I don't call the cops.
我不给警察打电话。
You haven't-- you don't call 911.
你还没——你没打过911。
I never call it for any reason whatsoever. Everything can be handled within a community-- every possible situation you can come up with.
我从来不会因为任何理由打那个电话。所有的事情都可以在社区内处理——你能想到的任何可能的情况。
Does it make sense to you why he would have said that, though?
但是他为什么会这么说，这对你来说有道理吗？
Yeah, because he's been acculturated to a system which believes that we will always need policing, no matter what, even though it's an advent of the 18th century.
有，因为他已经被文化熏陶进入了一个系统，该系统认为无论如何我们永远需要警务，即使这是18世纪的产物。
Wait, are you saying a rehearsed speech?
等等，你在背诵讲稿吗？
My entire life is dedicated to the destruction of the police and the American empire. I'm speaking off the cuff because this is what I think about all day long.
我的一生都致力于摧毁警察和美帝国。我是在即兴发言，因为这就是我整天在思考的事情。
Another protester came in soon after Josh and Katie. She was also skeptical of the police. Her tactic, though, was pretty different.
乔什和凯蒂之后不久又有一位抗议者进来。她也对警察持怀疑态度。不过她的策略非常不同。
This was a white protester I noticed in front of the sliced cheeses, animatedly chatting up a black police officer. She was asking him questions, which he seemed to be answering. This was a kind of conversation I hadn't heard yet, and so I walked over.
这是一位我在切片奶酪前注意到的白人抗议者，正兴致勃勃地和一名黑人警官聊天。她在问他问题，他似乎在回答。这是我还没听到过的一种谈话，所以我走了过去。
Lieutenant Maurice Walston was wearing an upper rank officer's white shirt. Brianna was holding a green juice. She was on her way home from drinks with her friend after protesting all day.
莫里斯·沃尔斯顿（Maurice Walston）中尉穿着高级军官的白衬衫。布里安娜（Brianna）拿着一杯绿汁。她在抗议了一整天后，在和朋友喝完酒回家的路上。
And I appreciate you just talking to me.
我感谢你愿意和我说话。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and that's-- I mean, absolutely.
是的，是的，是的，那——我是说，绝对。
Officer Walston, I really appreciate this conversation just in general.
沃尔斯顿警官，我真的很感谢这次谈话。
Yep, no problem. And I appreciate it as well. And again, it should be everyone's right that no one should be able to-- no one should fear police interactions like this. We should all--
是的，没问题。我也很感激。再说一次，这应该是每个人的权利，没有人应该能够——没有人应该像这样害怕警察互动。我们都应该——
I don't.
我不害怕。
No, I know that. But I'm sure--
不，我知道这一点。但我敢肯定——
But that's my privilege, right? I don't have to.
但那是我的特权，对吧？我不必害怕。
Lieutenant Walston doesn't want to talk about her privilege.
沃尔斯顿中尉不想谈论她的特权。
Well, I can tell you this. When I deal with even people of my race, I give them the same respect that I give to you. And that's just across the board.
好吧，我可以告诉你这一点。当我处理即使是我自己种族的人时，我也给予他们我给予你的同样的尊重。这在各方面都是如此。
I'm sure you do. That's not the question, right? You're an officer of color.
我相信你做得到。那不是问题所在，对吧？你是一名有色人种警官。
But that's your question. You have a different question, right.
但那是你的问题。你有不同的问题，对吧。
That is my question, yes, but I've been-- this is not my first conversation with a police officer tonight.
那确实是我的问题，是的，但我已经——这不是我今晚第一次和警官谈话了。
No, I understand. No, I get it. I understand.
不，我理解。不，我明白。我理解。
I want to communicate and understand.
我想沟通和理解。
It's a really awkward conversation to watch. She keeps making big statements about policing, ending with, "Right?"
观看这场谈话真的很尴尬。她不断发表关于警务的大言论，最后都以“对吧？”结尾。
It's not an isolated event here or there, right? It's a systemic problem. I have this general sense that people who go to be police officers generally have a power issue. Right? Either it's a power issue, or they want to help people. And in my mind, it's one or the other.
这不是这里或那里的孤立事件，对吧？这是一个系统性的问题。我有一种普遍的感觉，即那些成为警察的人通常都有权力问题。对吧？要么是权力问题，要么是想帮助别人。在我看来，二者必居其一。
I think generally, most people become police officers to help people.
我认为通常大多数人成为警察是为了帮助别人。
And of course, it's hard to get Lieutenant Walston to agree with what seems to be her central premise, that there's something fundamentally wrong with his job.
当然，很难让沃尔斯顿中尉同意她似乎的核心前提，即他的工作有某种根本性的错误。
But ultimately, when police are called in on peacekeeping missions, violence ensues, right?
但归根结底，当警察被派去执行维和任务时，暴力就会随之而来，对吧？
See, there are times when we get called, and violence has already occurred or violence is there. And that's the majority of the times why we're getting called to these emergency situations.
你看，我们被叫去的时候，暴力已经发生了，或者暴力就在那里。这就是我们被叫去应对这些紧急情况的大多数情况。
Lieutenant Walston told me later that people who don't have as many interactions with the police often fill the vacuum with the worst images they see in the news, not anything based on their own experiences.
沃尔斯顿中尉后来告诉我，那些与警察互动较少的人经常会用他们在新闻中看到的最糟糕的形象来填补空白，而不是基于他们自己的经历。
His strategy during this conversation, he told me, was first to mostly just listen. But when she told him she knew what it was like to be in the minority because she'd lived as a white person in Oakland, he realized the depth of her misconceptions. But since she seemed so adamant, he wasn't out to change them.
他告诉我，他在这次谈话中的策略首先主要是倾听。但当她告诉他，因为她曾在奥克兰作为白人生活过，所以她知道作为少数群体是什么感觉时，他意识到了她误解的深度。但由于她看起来如此固执，他并不打算改变她的想法。
When we talked to Brianna later, she said she wasn't expecting to change anything about his beliefs. It just felt important to say what she thought. Toward the end of their 20-minute conversation, there is a moment where she asks for his advice. She asks, do you have kids?
当我们后来和布里安娜谈话时，她说她没指望改变他的信仰。说出她的想法感觉很重要。在他们20分钟谈话快结束时，有一个时刻她询问了他的建议。她问，你有孩子吗？
Yeah, I do. I have twins.
是的，我有。我有双胞胎。
I have a four-year-old son. He's biracial. And I'm trying to figure out how to tell him he presents as white. He looks white. But he's not white, right? So how do you talk to a biracial kid about racism?
我有一个四岁的儿子。他是混血。我正试图弄清楚如何告诉他他看起来像白人。他看起来很白。但他不是白人，对吧？所以你如何与一个混血孩子谈论种族主义？
Right.
对。
So that's why I asked.
所以我才问。
Right, no, I understand.
对，不，我理解。
How do you talk to your black kids about police brutality?
你是如何与你的黑人孩子谈论警察暴力的？
They're also biracial, so I'm honest with them. That's the only way you can be. Be honest, and--
他们也是混血，所以我对他们很诚实。那是你能做到的唯一方式。要诚实，并且——
What does the honesty look like?
诚实是什么样子的？
Well, honestly looks like me, in part. Tell them that there are officers like me out there, you know?
嗯，诚实的一部分就是像我一样。告诉他们外面有像我这样的警官，你知道吗？
Do you also have to tell them there's officers that's not like you?
你也必须告诉他们有不像你这样的警官吗？
Yes, I would be truthful.
是的，我会说实话。
You have to have that conversation with your kids.
你必须和你的孩子进行那样的谈话。
You have to have that conversation with your kids, she tells him. It's funny to imagine how different those two conversations would be. After she left, I asked Lieutenant Walston what you've made of all of that.
你必须和你的孩子进行那样的谈话，她告诉他。想象那两次谈话会有多大不同，真是很有趣。她走后，我问沃尔斯顿中尉你对这一切有什么看法。
Have you been having more conversations like the one you just had? Sorry, to be more specific, have more white people wanted to talk to you about that kind of thing than usual?
你最近有进行更多像刚才那样的谈话吗？抱歉，具体来说，是否有比平时更多的白人想和你谈论这类事情？
Yeah. Yeah, and I get that. Let me just say this. I'm actually, I'm happy that you have all nationalities that are coming together to come and go. And I'm happy about that. The only thing is that when you do get a white person, which is fine, but the one thing I just don't allow is for you to claim that you know my plight more than I do.
是的。是的，我懂。让我说这一点。其实，我很高兴你们所有民族的人都聚在一起。我对此感到高兴。唯一的问题是，当你确实遇到一个白人时，这没问题，但我绝不允许的一点是，你声称你比我更了解我的困境。
Is it accurate to say that that was like a white lady explaining to you why black lives matter?
准确地说，那是一个白人女士向你解释为什么黑人的生命很重要吗？
Yeah. Yeah, basically. In a sense, yeah. It's someone not of my race telling me why my life matters. And I know why my life matters. I know what I went through.
是的。是的，基本上。从某种意义上说，是的。那是某人不是我的种族在告诉我为什么我的生命很重要。我知道为什么我的生命很重要。我知道我经历了什么。
He gets in an unmarked police car with his patrol partner and drives down Lafayette Avenue.
他坐上一辆便衣警车和他的巡逻伙伴开车沿拉斐特大道行驶。
By 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning, the protesters recede off the stage, and the night shift workers make their entrance. The mood changes again. It becomes quiet, contemplative. The night shift workers, they aren't on their way home from protesting racism. But many of them know a lot about it, like Alexander.
到了凌晨1点或2点，抗议者退出了舞台，夜班工人登场了。气氛再次改变。变得安静、沉思。夜班工人，他们不是从抗议种族主义的路上回家。但他们许多人对此了解很多，比如亚历山大（Alexander）。
I do security for 300 Ashland.
我为阿什兰300号（300 Ashland）做安保。
OK, is it that big fancy building on the corner?
好的，是那个拐角处的漂亮大楼吗？
Yeah. Exactly.
是的。正是。
What's that job like right now? Has it been hectic at all because of the protests?
现在那份工作怎么样？因为抗议活动变得忙乱了吗？
Not really, but people-- it's just that you get surprised to see who has their position politically on the protest from working in a residential building. Some people come out to jump with the protesters. Some people come out and go get the protesters. So you get to see-- you know.
并不完全是，但人们——只是你会惊讶于看到谁在住宅楼工作，在抗议活动中持什么政治立场。有些人出来和抗议者一起跳。有些人出来去针对抗议者。所以你可以看到——你知道。
Huh. Do people kind of match up with what you would guess?
哈。人们会和你猜测的一致吗？
Yeah, this is surprising how being cynical is usually being right. [LAUGHS]
是的，令人惊讶的是，变得愤世嫉俗通常是正确的。（笑声）
Though there is one wildcard category.
虽然有一个通配符类别。
The older residents are always surprising on their views. Because at a certain age, you start to be like OK, I don't expect much from you. [LAUGHS]
年长的居民在他们的观点上总是令人惊讶。因为到了某个年纪，你开始想，好吧，我不指望你有什么表现。（笑声）
There's some older woke people in your building.
你们大楼里有一些年长的觉醒人士。
Yeah, when they're awake, they ain't know what's going on. It's surprising, you know? That feels nice.
是的，当他们醒着时，他们知道发生了什么。这很令人惊讶，你知道吗？那感觉不错。
Wait, what kinds of things are people saying who are against the protest?
等等，反对抗议的人在说什么？
It's more of like, the subtle hints would be, oh, when is it going to be enough of these people protesting? That or it's too late for that. Or now, is this usually the time? Or why didn't y'all do that the last time, you know? It's subtle when people try to diminish or water down the situation. But it is what it is. Ain't nothing us as a people aren't used to, so.
更多的是像这样，微妙的暗示会是，哦，这些抗议的人什么时候才够了？或者是那已经太晚了。或者现在，这是通常的时候吗？或者你们上次为什么不做那个，你知道吗？当人们试图贬低或淡化局势时，这很微妙。但事实就是如此。这并没有什么我们作为一个民族不习惯的，所以。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Like, being a black individual, you're used to people always dismissing your cause. Like, if we talk about slavery, they bring up the Holocaust. If we talk about anything that's about being black, other people bring in their struggles, too. So it is what it is.
就像作为一个黑人，你习惯了人们总是驳回你的事业。就像我们谈论奴隶制，他们就提起大屠杀。如果我们谈论任何关于黑人的事，其他人也会带入他们的挣扎。所以事实就是如此。
So even with the protests now, nothing wrong with I see Caucasian friends helping us out and being a part of the situation. But it's getting watered down because everybody sees the white faces. They're not seeing any black face as a part of it. So whose lives matter? Mm, I don't know. [LAUGHS]
所以即使现在有抗议，看到高加索朋友帮助我们并参与其中并没有什么错。但它正在被淡化，因为每个人都看到了白人面孔。他们没有看到任何黑人面孔参与其中。那么谁的生命重要呢？嗯，我不知道。（笑声）
The vast majority of the protesters we talked to at Mr. Mango that night were, in fact, white.
那天晚上我们在芒果先生交谈的绝大多数抗议者，事实上，都是白人。
How has it been working after curfew? Does it feel-- have you been nervous about it at all?
宵禁后工作感觉如何？感觉——你对此感到紧张吗？
No, I haven't been nervous. I'm not a nervous individual. Yeah, because this is all-- this is all riots, and never know whether you're going to be attacked or not or feeling unsafe. It's part of being a black male, period. So it's a little bit of insight for everybody else to feel like how we feel, you know?
不，我没感到紧张。我不是个紧张的人。是的，因为这一切——这都是暴动，永远不知道你是否会被攻击，或者是否感到不安全。这是作为一个黑人男性的部分，句号。所以对其他人来说，这是一个小小的洞察，让他们感觉我们是如何感觉的，你知道吗？
Alexander works the night shift from 6:00 PM to 2:00 AM, which has made getting home hard during this week of curfew. The subway is closed. Cabs aren't an option. Alexander is 26 and has lived in New York City his whole life. He told me that the first time a Yellow Cab stopped for him as a black man was this last year. Tonight, he heard Uber is running, and that's how he'll get home.
亚历山大做从下午6点到凌晨2点的夜班，这使得他在本周宵禁期间回家变得困难。地铁关闭了。出租车不是一个选择。亚历山大今年26岁，一辈子都住在纽约市。他告诉我，作为黑人，黄色出租车第一次为他停下是在去年。今晚，他听说优步（Uber）在运营，那就是他回家的方式。
How did you get home the other night?
你那天晚上是怎么回家的？
Through the grace of God. [LAUGHS] That's the only way possible to describe it.
靠上帝的恩典。（笑声）那是描述它的唯一可能方式。
Right now, though, he has to get back to work. He walks over to the cash register.
不过，现在他必须回去工作。他走到收银台。
You know what? I'm the type of person that when I buy stuff, sometimes I get all the things that are the same color. I don't know why. I think other people do it, too, but somehow I got Ramune and it looked like blueberries.
你知道吗？我是那种买东西时有时会买所有颜色一样的东西的人。我不知道为什么。我想其他人也会这样做，但不知怎么的我买了Ramune，它看起来像蓝莓。
It looks like you got all purple today. You got purple Ramune and an acai drink.
看起来你今天买的都是紫色的。你买了紫色Ramune和巴西莓饮料。
And somehow I got this grape juice, too. I don't know why. It's hilarious, huh? [LAUGHS]
不知怎么的我还买了葡萄汁。我不知道为什么。很搞笑，对吧？（笑声）
Have a good night.
祝你有美好的一晚。
You, too.
你也是。
At around 1:30 AM, a guy in an MTA uniform walked in. He was holding a big leather binder. He heads straight for the cash register, eager to show Dorje whatever is inside of it. It's a trading card album, full of old basketball cards, the kind with holograms.
凌晨1点半左右，一个穿着MTA制服的人走了进来。他手里拿着一个大皮夹子。他径直走向收银台，急于向多吉展示里面装的东西。那是一本集换式卡片册，装满了旧篮球卡，那种带有全息图的。
Yeah, this is from the 1990s when Michael Jordan dominated. There's Michael Jordan. This is the famous nuts and bolts collection. I'm going to give 500 for that. It's 10 cards. Everybody's in the Hall of Fame. See? Look at that.
是的，这是来自迈克尔·乔丹称霸的1990年代。那是迈克尔·乔丹。这是著名的螺母和螺栓系列。我要为那个付出500。有10张卡。每个人都在名人堂。看到了吗？看那个。
His name is Fred Nixon. He works for the city subway system, specifically the G stop beneath the store.
他的名字是弗雷德·尼克松（Fred Nixon）。他为城市地铁系统工作，具体是在商店下方的G站。
I work right downstairs in the booth. Yeah, I got to-- don't you see I need a napkin since I'm on TV, man?
我在楼下的摊位工作。是啊，我得——难道你没看见我在电视上吗，伙计，我需要一张餐巾纸？
Fred comes into Mr. Mango a lot, when he gets hot downstairs. The napkin he asked for was to wipe the sweat from his forehead. He and Dorje talk all the time. They know each other well.
弗雷德经常来芒果先生，当他在楼下感到热的时候。他要的餐巾纸是用来擦掉额头上的汗水。他和多吉经常交谈。他们非常了解彼此。
Is it crazy people outside also?
外面的人也疯了吗？
No, no, it's died down now.
不，不，现在平息下来了。
Fred starts talking about the looting.
弗雷德开始谈论抢劫。
You know the reason why people did that, because Donald Trump is an idiot. And he said when the looting starts, the shooting starts. People in America, they take that to heart, and they say, oh, yeah? Shoot me. And that's what that was all about. But I'm glad they stopped. I really believe that's why the people looted because they wanted to challenge him, you know?
你知道人们为什么那么做，因为唐纳德·特朗普是个白痴。他说当抢劫开始，射击就开始了。美国的人们，他们把那放在心上，他们说，哦，真的吗？射我啊。这就是全部的原因。但我很高兴他们停下来了。我真的相信这就是人们抢劫的原因，因为他们想挑战他，你知道吗？
Like they felt dared to.
就像他们觉得被挑衅了一样。
Yeah.
是的。
Fred Nixon is 61 years old. He's black, grew up here in the same neighborhood. And he's proud of these past couple of weeks. He feels the protests are a continuation of work he had a hand in starting.
弗雷德·尼克松今年61岁。他是黑人，就在这同一个社区长大。他为过去这几周感到自豪。他觉得抗议活动是他参与开启的工作的延续。
Yeah, I started this movement 40 years ago right across the street at Bam with Sonny Carson.
是的，我40年前就在街对面的Bam与桑尼·卡森（Sonny Carson）一起开始了这项运动。
Wait, [INAUDIBLE].
等等，（无法听清）。
Sonny Carson actually was trying to do something like this 40 years ago. Go look that up.
桑尼·卡森40年前确实试图做类似这样的事情。去查查那个。
I did. Sonny Carson was a civil rights activist and a political organizer from Brooklyn. In the 1970s, he led demonstrations for racial justice, just a block away from Mr. Mango.
我查了。桑尼·卡森是一位来自布鲁克林的民权活动家和政治组织者。在1970年代，他领导了种族正义的示威活动，就在离芒果先生一个街区的地方。
How does it make you feel seeing it happen again now in 2020?
看到它现在在2020年再次发生，你有什么感觉？
I wanted to see it before I'm dead, so I'm glad about it because black people can't do it by themselves. And until everybody jumped in the course, that's why nobody was listening.
我想在死前看到它，所以我为此感到高兴，因为黑人不能独自做到这一点。在每个人都加入进来之前，这就是为什么没人听。
What do you think is different now, though, that-- I mean, basically, more white people than ever are paying attention. What do you think is different?
你认为现在有什么不同，尽管——我是说，基本上，比以往任何时候都多的白人在关注。你认为有什么不同？
I think that-- you ever heard the saying, the straw that broke the camel's back?
我认为——你听说过那句谚语吗，压死骆驼的最后一根稻草？
Of course.
当然。
George Floyd was the straw that broke the camel's back.
乔治·弗洛伊德就是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。
Part of Fred's job is interfacing with cops patrolling the subway station often.
弗雷德工作的一部分是经常与在地铁站巡逻的警察对接。
Sometimes when I see cops, I get really upset about it. When I was 15 years old, I got beat up by the cops right in front of the 88th precinct.
有时当我看到警察时，我会对此非常生气。我15岁时，就在第88分局前被警察打了。
Where's the 88th pre-- where is it?
第88分局在哪里——它在哪里？
On Carson and DeKalb. And recently, they tried to burn it up last week. I didn't even feel bad for them because of that experience I had when I was 15 years old.
在卡森和德卡尔布（Carson and DeKalb）。最近，他们上周试图烧掉它。我甚至没为他们感到难过，因为我15岁时的那种经历。
It was the early '70s when it happened. Fred said it was a misunderstanding about unpaid bus fare, which, at the time, was $0.35. He says not a lot's changed since then.
那是70年代初发生的事。弗雷德说这是一个关于未付公交车费的误会，当时是0.35美元。他说从那以后没发生多少变化。
I've been stopped by the cops with my uniform on. The cops came to my job and told me I stole a Red Bull at the store with my uniform on. And I was going crazy. I was like-- I told them if they didn't get out of my booth, I was going to press the emergency button. They all left. Because they know they have to fill out paperwork for that.
我穿着制服被警察拦下过。警察来到我的工作场所，告诉我我穿着制服在店里偷了红牛。我疯了。我就像——我告诉他们如果他们不离开我的摊位，我就要按紧急按钮。他们都离开了。因为他们知道他们必须为此填写文书工作。
Fred didn't buy anything at Mr. Mango, not during that break anyway. He just came in to say hi to Dorje.
弗雷德在芒果先生没买任何东西，至少在那次休息时没买。他只是进来和多吉打个招呼。
Yeah, this is the place, man. Mr. Mango is the best. Especially Mr. Dorje here.
是的，这是个好地方，伙计。芒果先生是最棒的。尤其是这里多吉先生。
Mr. Dorje.
多吉先生。
On his way out, Fred promised Dorje that he'd bring back the basketball cards soon so he could get a proper look. Dorje said he'd want a full hour to do it, so that he can see everything.
临走时，弗雷德向多吉承诺他会很快带回篮球卡，这样他就能好好看看了。多吉说他想要整整一小时来看，这样他才能看到一切。
After 3:00 AM, even the night shift workers weren't coming in anymore. It was just Dorje and Ronny in there. They were in constant motion-- Ronny restocking the eggs and coconut water, Dorje cleaning the coffee machine and rearranging the pastries. Around 3:30, a really out of it man walked in. He was black. It seemed like he might have been homeless. He got a muffin.
凌晨3点后，连夜班工人也不再进来了。店里只剩多吉和罗尼。他们一直在忙碌——罗尼补充鸡蛋和椰子水，多吉清理咖啡机并重新摆放糕点。大约3点半，一个真的很恍惚的男人走了进来。他是黑人。看起来他可能无家可归。他拿了一个松饼。
After that, no one came in. And the store felt like a safe, clean cocoon, full of soap and honey and different kinds of sprinkles. It felt like a store from six months ago, or 100 months ago, where nothing was out of place, except maybe the case of hand sanitizer above the cheesecake fridge.
之后，没其他人进来了。这家店感觉就像一个安全、干净的茧，充满了肥皂、蜂蜜和各种各样的糖屑。它感觉像六个月前，或100个月前的商店，没有什么是格格不入的，除了也许芝士蛋糕冰箱上面的那箱洗手液。
The last person we talked to as we left at 5:00 AM was a Latino guy picking over the oranges in a crisp Hawaiian shirt. He was complaining about a notice from the government that his student loans from the '80s were overdue. He was so annoyed. No pandemic or protest on his mind at all in that moment.
凌晨5点我们离开时交谈的最后一个人是一个拉丁裔家伙，正穿着一件清脆的夏威夷衬衫在挑选橙子。他一直在抱怨政府的一份通知，说他80年代的学生贷款逾期了。他非常烦躁。那一刻，他脑子里根本没想大流行或抗议。
Diane Wu with Lina Misitzis. Coming up, a neighborhood protest that wasn't supposed to happen. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
戴安·吴（Diane Wu）与莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）。接下来，一场本不应该发生的社区抗议活动。就在芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续后的那一分钟。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Here Again, the stories in the aftermath of the killing of George Floyd that we recorded this past week.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《再次来到这里》，我们记录了本周乔治·弗洛伊德被杀后的故事。
So there are these Twitter threads that have sprung up these last couple weeks where people were collecting as many videos of police violence against protesters as they can find. I spent a lot of time scrolling through the ones assembled by a North Carolina lawyer named T. Greg Doucette. He's also got them in handy Google Doc form online. He has over 600 videos so far, and he says people have sent him 1,600 direct messages with links that he hasn't even gotten to yet.
过去几周推特上出现了许多线程，人们在收集尽可能多的警察暴力对抗议者的视频。我花了很多时间浏览由一位名叫T·格雷格·杜塞特（T. Greg Doucette）的北卡罗来纳州律师整理的那些。他还在网上以方便的Google文档形式整理了它们。他目前拥有超过600个视频，他说人们给他发送了1600条直接消息，其中包含他甚至还没来得及看的链接。
The stuff that police are doing in these videos, I mean, the tactics that they're using against peaceful protests, it is not news. There's nothing new about it. At this point, I think everybody knows or should know that this stuff is happening. But watching them back to back, all collected in one place, the sheer concentrated volume of it is unnerving. The simplest ones start with utterly peaceful demonstrators.
警察在这些视频中所做的事，我是说，他们对抗和平抗议使用的策略，这并不是新闻。没什么新鲜的。在这一点上，我认为每个人都知道或应该知道这些事情正在发生。但连续观看它们，全部收集在一个地方，那种纯粹集中的数量是令人不安的。最简单的是从完全和平的示威者开始。
This is what democracy looks like!
这就是民主的样子！
In San Luis Obispo, Bentonville, Arkansas, Columbus, Ohio, Huntsville, Georgia, Walnut Creek, California-- too many places to name. And then police fired tear gas and sometimes flash bangs or rubber bullets with no apparent provocation.
在圣路易斯奥比斯波、本顿维尔、阿肯色、哥伦布、俄亥俄、亨茨维尔、佐治亚、核桃溪、加利福尼亚——太多地方无法一一列举。然后警察在没有任何明显挑衅的情况下发射了催泪瓦斯，有时还有闪光弹或橡胶子弹。
Oh, shit! Oh, fuck! Oh, shit! Run, run, run, run! [INAUDIBLE]
噢，该死！噢，操！噢，该死！跑，跑，跑，跑！（无法听清）
Lots of videos, of course, get way more violent. In Austin, police shot a bean bag round at a 16-year-old boy, Brad Levi Ayala. He seems like he's just a bystander, watching the protests from an embankment near the street.
当然，很多视频要暴力得多。在奥斯汀，警察向16岁男孩布拉德·利维·阿亚拉（Brad Levi Ayala）发射了布袋弹。他看起来只是个旁观者，从街道附近的堤岸观看抗议活动。
Jesus Christ!
上帝啊！
Murder! Murder! Murder!
谋杀！谋杀！谋杀！
In Minneapolis, on a super peaceful, suburban looking, tree-lined street with pretty homes, police and National Guard marched down the street.
在明尼阿波利斯，在一条看起来非常和平、郊区化、绿树成荫、房屋漂亮的街道上，警察和国民警卫队在大街上行进。
Get inside!
进去！
Get in your house now! Let's go!
现在进你们的房子！走！
And fire some kind of a round at a woman for the offense of videoing them from her own porch.
并因一个女人在自己门廊上录像的“罪行”而向她发射了某种弹药。
Go inside now! Get in the home!
现在进去！进屋里去！
Ah! Ah!
啊！啊！
In Los Angeles, a black family tries to protect a store from looters. They flag down police to help, and then, the police start to handcuff and detain them. A reporter who's there on live TV tries to set the police straight.
在洛杉矶，一个黑人家庭试图保护一家商店免受抢劫者侵害。他们挥手示意警察协助，然后，警察开始给他们戴上手铐并拘留他们。一位在现场进行电视直播的记者试图纠正警察。
OK, sir, sir.
好的，先生，先生。
Whoa.
哇。
They're protecting the store. The looters are over there.
他们在保护商店。抢劫者在那边。
Stand down for a sec, please.
请站住一会儿。
In Indianapolis, an officer looks like he grabs a young woman's breasts while trying to detain her. She squirms free. And two officers beat her to the ground with nightsticks.
在印第安纳波利斯，一名警官在试图拘留一名年轻女子时，看起来抓住了她的胸部。她挣脱了。两名警官用警棍将她殴打在地。
Get on the ground.
趴在地上。
This is going to be the last one I'm going to play you. It sums up, I think, all of these as well as any one video could. It's from Charleston, South Carolina. Again, a perfectly peaceful group of protesters, all of them kneeling-- I don't know-- maybe 20 feet from a line of police. There's one guy who addresses officers.
这将是我要播放给你们看的最后一个视频。我认为它和任何一个视频一样，概括了所有这一切。它来自南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿。同样，一群非常和平的抗议者，他们全都跪着——我不知道——距离警察线可能只有20英尺。有一个家伙对着警察说话。
I am not your enemy. You are not my enemy. I love all of y'all. You are my family, and I love you. And I respect you. And I want to understand y'all. I want to understand all of you.
我不是你的敌人。你不是我的敌人。我爱你们所有人。你们是我的家人，我爱你们。我尊重你们。我想理解你们。我想理解你们所有人。
He repeats this over and over. I want to understand you. Police respond by marching over to the guy, they drag him to his feet, and arrest him.
他一遍又一遍地重复这一点。我想理解你们。警察的反应是向那个人行进，他们将他拖起来并逮捕了他。
Come on, what are you doing?
来吧，你在做什么？
What are you doing?
你在做什么？
Fuck you! Fuck you! What the fuck did he do?
操你的！操你的！他到底做了什么？
Are you fucking kidding me?
你在跟我开玩笑吗？
Which brings us to Act Three, Grand Army. So given the way protests have been going, some people do not want them in their own neighborhoods. There's a neighborhood in Brooklyn, Red Hook, where there was a debate about this.
这带我们到了第三幕，大军队（Grand Army）。所以考虑到抗议活动的进行方式，有些人不希望它们在自己的社区内发生。布鲁克林有一个社区，红钩（Red Hook），那里有一场关于此的辩论。
A couple weeks ago, one woman, who is white, woke up, read the news of the day, and then posted online that she wanted to have a protest. She got several responses from local community leaders asking her not to do it.
几周前，一位白人女性醒来，读了当天的新闻，然后在网上发帖说她想举行抗议活动。她收到了几位当地社区领袖的回复，要求她不要这样做。
The wife of a local pastor wrote, please reconsider this. There's more damage than good that will come from this. The hurt and anger that the black community has right now will not allow for this to end up peacefully. In the end, you will be able to go back home to a quiet peaceful block, but the residents of NYCHA-- that's the public housing-- won't. They will end up with more police presence, possible curfew, some may get hurt, and so much more.
一位当地牧师的妻子写道，请重新考虑。这带来的损害将大于利益。黑人社区现在所遭受的伤害和愤怒将不允许以和平方式结束。最终，你将能够回到一个安静和平的街区，但NYCHA（纽约市住房管理局）的居民——也就是公共住房居民——却不能。他们最终会面临更多的警察存在、可能的宵禁，一些人可能会受伤，还有更多。
The one who wrote the initial post backed down. But last weekend, there was a protest in Red Hook. One of our producers Dana Chivvis, who lives there, explains how that happened and how it went.
那个写了最初帖子的人退缩了。但上周末，红钩发生了一场抗议活动。我们住在那里的一位制片人达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）解释了它是如何发生的，以及它是如何进行的。
The protest that did happen was organized by a 22-year-old named Na Dortch, who had never done anything like this before. I met up with him just before the protest started.
发生的抗议是由一位名叫Na Dortch的22岁年轻人组织的，他以前从未做过这样的事。抗议开始前我见到了他。
Have you been in touch with the police? Have they contacted you as the organizer at all?
你和警察联系过了吗？作为组织者，他们联系过你吗？
Oh, yeah, they have.
哦，是的，他们联系过。
What have those conversations been like?
那些对话是什么样的？
They're just mainly interested in the route and what's going to happen and things like that.
他们主要是对路线和会发生什么之类的事情感兴趣。
Has it been cordial, your conversations with them?
你和他们的谈话是亲切的吗？
Oh, no, no, no, no, no. It's been-- it has been cordial. It has been cordial, but they say things like, so we need the route. And I say, I don't think you need the route. And they say, well, you don't have a permit. You know what I mean? Like, hey, if you don't give me the route, we're going to shut it down because you don't have a permit-- things like that.
哦，不，不，不，不，不。它一直——它一直很亲切。它一直很亲切，但他们说些事情，比如，我们需要路线。我说，我不认为你需要路线。他们说，好吧，你没有许可证。你知道我的意思吗？就像，嘿，如果你不给我路线，我们要关闭它，因为你没有许可证——诸如此类。
So you didn't give them the route.
所以你没给他们路线。
I didn't give them the route at all. I didn't give anyone the route. I gave people a general route.
我根本没给他们路线。我没给任何人路线。我给了人们一条大致的路线。
The police told me they didn't try to shut down the event. Three weeks ago, Na was doing what a lot of us were.
警察告诉我他们没试图关闭这次活动。三周前，Na在做我们许多人都在做的事情。
Literally, I was doing nothing. Literally nothing. I was just home in my house, doing nothing. Just going outside sometimes, getting some air, but I was doing nothing.
说真的，我什么都没做。真的什么都没做。我只是待在自己家里，什么都没做。只是有时出门，透透气，但我什么都没做。
And then George Floyd was killed. The country erupted in protest. Na looked out at his neighborhood and saw--
然后乔治·弗洛伊德被杀了。全国爆发了抗议。Na向外看着他的社区，看到了——
Nobody's coming to fucking Red Hook. And nobody's out here protesting, and I was just like, fuck it. I'm going to do a protest.
没人来该死的红钩。也没人出来抗议，我就想，去他妈的。我要举行一场抗议。
He'd been to a few protests over the years. When he was 17, he joined a Black Lives Matter group for a few days. But he felt like he was too young to make a difference, to be heard. Everyone else in the group was ancient, in their 30s.
这些年来他参加过几次抗议。17岁时，他加入了一个“黑人的命也是命”团体几天。但他觉得他太年轻了，无法产生改变，无法被倾听。团体内其他人都是老古董，30多岁。
He texted his friend Crystal. She agreed to be his secretary. Made a flyer with the date and time for the protest. Na pulled in his friends, Mo Pringle-- like the chimp, she told me-- Naseem Stevenson, who plans to go to law school, and a few others. They came up with a name-- the New BLQK Leaders, black spelled BLQK, because the other version was taken.
他给他的朋友克里斯托（Crystal）发了短信。她同意做他的秘书。制作了一张带有日期和时间的传单。Na拉来了他的朋友，莫·普林格尔（Mo Pringle）——就像那个黑猩猩，她告诉我——纳西姆·史蒂文森（Naseem Stevenson），他计划去读法学院，还有其他几个人。他们想出了一个名字——新的BLQK领袖，BLQK拼写为BLQK，因为另一个版本被占用了。
Objectively, 2020 has been an unremitting shit storm of a year, but things have actually been going OK for Na. He recently came out to his friends and family. Most of them were supportive. His grandmother asked a few awkward questions and then tried to get some hot gossip about who else was gay. He's been feeling more empowered lately, more like himself.
客观地说，2020年是这辈子让人极其心累的一年，但对Na来说事情进行得还不错。他最近向朋友和家人出柜了。他们中的大多数人都支持。他奶奶问了几个尴尬的问题，然后试图打听谁还是同性恋的八卦。他最近感觉更有力量了，更像他自己了。
But when he and some friends decided to have a protest, they got the same response from some community leaders as the other woman, the one who proposed a protest on Facebook. They worried it could be dangerous. People from outside the neighborhood could come in and start trouble. It could give the cops a reason to harass them or to get violent.
但当他和朋友决定举行抗议时，他们从一些社区领袖那里得到了和那位女性一样的反应，即那位在脸书上提议抗议的人。他们担心这可能会很危险。来自社区外的人可能会进来惹麻烦。这可能会给警察一个理由来骚扰他们或使用暴力。
One of them felt like people have been protesting for years, and nothing had changed. The New BLQK Leaders had a Zoom call where they tried to convince them everything would be fine.
其中一个人觉得人们已经抗议多年了，但什么都没改变。新的BLQK领袖开了一次Zoom会议，试图说服他们一切都会好起来的。
I'm going to express all throughout the protest, we do not want agitators here. If you see anyone who's trying to agitate, stop them. If you feel like you are going to get agitated or if you are here to be violent, leave. I'm going to constantly express that.
我将在整个抗议过程中表达，我们不想要煽动者在这里。如果你看到任何试图煽动的人，阻止他们。如果你觉得你会感到激动或如果你在这里是为了暴力，离开。我会不断地表达这一点。
After this call with the community leaders, though, one of them, a guy who serves as a community liaison to the 76th precinct, sent an email to the police, telling them what route he thought the march would take and giving them the names and photos of the organizers. It made Na feel even more targeted than he already did.
不过，在这次与社区领袖的通话后，其中一个人，一位担任第76分局社区联络员的家伙，给警察发了一封电子邮件，告诉他们他认为游行路线会是怎样，并给他们提供了组织者的姓名和照片。这让Na觉得比他已经感到的更加像是一个目标。
It hurt me. It almost discouraged me, because it made me feel like, damn, nobody believes in us. You know what I mean? Even though we constantly express how it was going to go and we expressed that, you can help us make sure that these things remain-- like, the protest is safe. But it almost discouraged me. It kind of made me feel like, I didn't know what I was doing.
它伤害了我。它几乎让我灰心，因为它让我觉得，妈的，没人相信我们。你知道我的意思吗？尽管我们一直在表达这将如何进行，我们表达了你可以帮助我们确保这些事情保持——比如，抗议是安全的。但它几乎让我灰心。它让我有点觉得，我不知道我在做什么。
Na's friends, the other organizers, convinced him to keep going. And that email, it was actually the reason one of the reticent community leaders, Tiffiney Davis, decided to go to the protest.
Na的朋友，其他组织者，说服他继续前进。那封电子邮件，实际上就是一位犹豫不决的社区领袖蒂芬妮·戴维斯（Tiffiney Davis）决定去参加抗议的原因。
It's a crazy day-- it's an empowering, but scary day.
这是一个疯狂的日子——这是一个充满力量但又令人恐惧的日子。
Tiffiney runs an organization called Red Hook Art Project. On Sunday, the day of the protest, she showed up early. A handful of people were hanging around outside the community center, getting ready, making signs and T-shirts.
蒂芬妮经营一个名为“红钩艺术项目”（Red Hook Art Project）的组织。周日，抗议当天，她提前到了。社区中心外面有几个人在溜达，准备着，制作标语和T恤。
What are you scared about?
你在怕什么？
I'm just seeing a lot of the police ride around in ways that they-- I mean, they always patrol the neighborhood, but they're patrolling it way too much now. Because they know that there's black leaders behind this protest. And they're looking for them to do something that that's not what their intentions are.
我只是看到很多警察以他们——我的意思是，他们总是巡逻社区，但他们现在巡逻得太多了。因为他们知道这场抗议背后有黑人领袖。他们正在寻找他们去做一些不是他们意图的事情。
You're seeing them drive around more today?
你今天看到他们到处开车的次数更多了吗？
I did see them drive around today, and I'm a little frustrated by what I'm seeing. As of now, I'm frustrated because these are young children. They're all my son and my daughter's age, so I'm very disappointed at the community police. I'm very disappointed.
我确实看到他们今天到处开车，我对所看到的有点沮丧。到目前为止，我很沮丧，因为这些都是年轻的孩子。他们都是我儿子和女儿的年纪，所以我对社区警察感到非常失望。我非常失望。
What are you worried might happen?
你担心可能会发生什么？
I don't know, just that any kid can make a wrong move. Like that gentleman right now is bouncing a basketball. What if the basketball rolled over and hit a police officer, and then they try to blame that on something negative and a reason to start shooting? Look at them. Do they look like they want to start trouble?
我不知道，只是任何孩子都可能犯错。比如那个绅士现在正在拍球。如果篮球滚过去撞到警察，然后他们试图把这归咎于负面原因并作为开始射击的理由怎么办？看看他们。他们看起来像是想找麻烦吗？
No, they look like they want to make T-shirts and signs.
不，他们看起来像是想做T恤和标语。
They just want opportunities to be seen and heard and respected.
他们只是想要被看见、被倾听和被尊重的机会。
The signs and T-shirts had George Floyd's face on them and Black Lives Matter-- and also, Forever Deion. Deion Fludd was a kid from Red Hook who died in 2013. He went through a subway turnstile without paying. Some cops tried to arrest him, and he jumped into the subway tracks to get away.
标语和T恤上有乔治·弗洛伊德的脸和“黑人的命也是命”——还有，永远的迪翁（Forever Deion）。迪翁·弗拉德（Deion Fludd）是红钩的一个孩子，2013年去世。他没买票就通过了地铁旋转门。警察试图逮捕他，他跳上地铁轨道逃跑。
He ended up in the hospital, paralyzed from the neck down in a coma and shackled to the bed. The police say he was hit by a train, but his family says he woke up from the coma and told them the police had beaten him and left him on the subway tracks. He died from the injuries not long after.
他最终进了医院，脖子以下瘫痪陷入昏迷，并被锁在床上。警察说他被火车撞了，但他家人说他从昏迷中醒来告诉他们警察殴打了并将他遗弃在地铁轨道上。他不久后因伤去世。
When 4:00 PM comes, there are probably 100 to 200 people waiting for the protest to begin. Na is walking around with a bullhorn in hand. He's tall, wearing a white Black Lives Matter T-shirt. His mask is around his chin.
下午4点到来时，可能有100到200人在等待抗议开始。Na拿着扩音器走来走去。他很高，穿着一件白色的“黑人的命也是命”T恤。他的口罩在他下巴上。
Na, are you nervous?
Na，你紧张吗？
I'm a little nervous.
我有点紧张。
Are you used to talking to this many people?
你习惯和这么多人说话吗？
I've been in front of this many people doing other things, just not talking. But I'm not worried about the talking. My eyes are on a mission, on a prize. I don't really-- I'm not thinking too much about my speech or anything.
我曾在这么多人面前做过其他事情，只是不是说话。但我不是担心说话。我的眼睛盯着一个任务，盯着一个奖赏。我真的——我没想太多关于我的演讲之类的事。
You don't be nervous, man. You stand up--
你别紧张，伙计。你站起来——
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm not that nervous. I'm just a little-- I'm shocked, really.
是啊，是啊，是啊。我没那么紧张。我只是有点——我很震惊，真的。
Is it more people than you thought there would be here or what?
那是比你想象的更多的人在这里吗？
A lot more people than I thought would be here.
比我想象中要多得多的人在这里。
It's a lot, huh?
很多，对吧？
Yeah. I need everybody to repeat after me. One mic.
是的。我要每个人跟着我重复。一个麦克风。
One mic.
一个麦克风。
All right, at 4:15, we will start moving. Right now, we are just waiting for other people to come. I'm so glad to see so many people out here. Let's give a round of applause because this is beautiful.
好了，在4点15分，我们将开始移动。现在，我们只是在等待其他人来。我很高兴看到这么多人来到这里。让我们鼓掌，因为这太美了。
Woo!
呜！
[CLAPPING]
[鼓掌]
For a guy who's never led a protest before, he seems totally at ease. There are also police there, about 10 of them by my count, including the commanding officer of the 76th precinct, which covers Red Hook, Deputy Inspector Megan O'Malley. She's talking to Naseem, Na's advance man, telling him certain streets are closed, including the block the 76th precinct is on.
对于一个从未领导过抗议的人来说，他看起来完全轻松。那里也有警察，依我数有大约10名，包括第76分局的指挥官，该分局覆盖红钩，副督察梅根·奥马利（Megan O'Malley）。她正在和Na的先遣人纳西姆说话，告诉他某些街道关闭了，包括第76分局所在的街区。
Did she say that was because of construction, or did she say--
她是说那是因为施工，还是她说——
Construction.
施工。
She said it was because of construction.
她说是因为施工，他们一直在制作莫洛托夫鸡尾酒（mocktails）。
She said it's construction, and they've been making mocktails.
哦，像莫洛托夫燃烧弹？
Oh, like molotov cocktails?
是啊，莫洛托夫鸡尾酒——
Yeah, mocktail--
像火焰弹？
Like the fire bombs?
是的。
Yep.
Na计划好了一切。他有骑手在人群中移动到游行队伍的最前面。接下来是六个人抬着一条写着“撤资警察”的横幅，以及一种越来越常见的策略——白人游行者被放在抗议队伍的最前面和两侧，想法是警察不太可能伤害他们。
Na's planned the whole thing out. He has the bikers in the crowd to move to the front of the march. Next come six people carrying a banner that reads, "Defund the Police," and a more and more common tactic-- the white marchers are put at the front of the protest and on the sides, the thought being that police will be less likely to harm them.
Na站在队伍前面，拳头举在空中。人群变得安静，也把拳头举在空中。然后——
Na stands in front of the group with his fists in the air. The crowd gets silent, puts their fists in the air, too. And then--
能请给我一些声音吗？
Can I have some noise please?
呜！
Woo!
[欢呼]
[CHEERING]
没有正义。
No justice.
没有和平。
No peace.
没有正义。
No justice.
没有和平。
No peace.
他领导着红钩的抗议活动。人群很兴奋。有一群年轻人。
He leads the protest through Red Hook. The crowd is amped. There are a bunch of young people.
这是我第一次看到整个国家聚在一起。我不打算撒谎。我爱它。
This is the first time I've seen the whole country together. I ain't even going to lie. I love it.
游行者前面有八九名警察，更多警察在人群两侧护卫。抗议者做着通常的欢呼——没有正义，没有和平。
Out in front of the marchers are eight or nine cops and more cops flanking the crowd. The protesters do the usual cheers-- no justice, no peace.
你怎么拼写种族主义者？
How do you spell racist?
纽约警察局。
NYPD.
你怎么拼写种族主义者？
How do you spell racist?
以及一些超本地化的口号。
As well as a few hyper local chants.
当我说是76时，你们说，吸我的鸡巴。76！
When I say 76, y'all say, suck my dick. 76!
吸我的鸡巴！
Suck my dick!
76！
76!
吸我的鸡巴！
Suck my dick!
警察像这样是不是有点奇怪——
Is it a little weird that the cops are like--
带头？带路，是的，非常奇怪。非常，非常。
Leading? Leading the way, yes, very weird. Very, very.
这是个名叫洛基·哈里斯（Rocky Harris）的家伙。
This is a guy named Rocky Harris.
我没指望他们中的任何一个。我以为他们会驱赶我们。他们实际上在带路。所以我不知道。
I wasn't expecting none of them. I thought they was gonna hound us. They actually leading the way. So I don't know.
副督察奥马利告诉我，警察在那儿是为了保护社区和游行者的安全。但游行者在那儿是为了抗议警察让他们感到不安全。
The cops are there to keep the community and the marchers safe, Deputy Inspector O'Malley told me. But the marchers were there to protest the cops for making them feel unsafe.
Na在人群中奔跑，从前到后，用他的扩音器领导口号。游行穿过公共住房高层建筑，一路吸引着人们。原本几百人的队伍不断扩大。
Na runs through the crowd, front to back, leading the chants with his bullhorn. The march winds through the public housing high rises, picking up people as it goes. What started as a couple hundred people just keeps growing.
我根本没想过会有这么多人——根本没想过。这很疯狂。我预料大约200人。这大约有500人。
I did not think there would be this many people at all-- at all. This is crazy. I expected, like, 200. This is, like, 500.
你在指挥这群人。
You are commanding this crowd.
是的，我得确保它保持现状。
Yeah, I got to make sure it stays in shape.
到目前为止，一切顺利。
So far, so good.
是的。
Yeah.
我发现计划的路线是穿过一座小桥，一座高速公路立交桥，并尽可能靠近第76分局，然后转身回到红钩。但当抗议接近时，Na改变了计划。他告诉一直在游行队伍前走、与警察沟通的纳西姆，他不想转身结束游行。进行得太顺利了。
The planned route, I find out, is to march over a little bridge, a highway overpass, and get as close as they can to the 76th precinct station, then turn and head back into Red Hook. But as the protest gets near, Na changes the plan. He tells Naseem, who's been walking out in front of the marchers, communicating with the police, that he doesn't want to turn around and end the march. It's going too well.
我们必须。人太多了，停不下来。我们可以去桥上，然后我们可以走到市中心。
We have to. There's too many people to stop. We could go to the bridge and then we could walk downtown.
好的。
OK.
市中心就是布鲁克林市中心，靠近巴克莱中心，那是过去几周很多抗议活动的地点。他们上了立交桥，穿过它，发现尽头有警察路障，那一排金属栅栏挡住了十字路口。他们不得不停下。数百人堆在高速公路上的这座桥上。这就是纳西姆告诉副督察奥马利Na想改变计划的地方。
Downtown is downtown Brooklyn, near the Barclays Center, which has been the location for a lot of protests these last few weeks. They get onto the overpass and cross it and find a police barricade at the end, a line of those metal fences blocking off the intersection. They have to stop. Hundreds of people pile onto this bridge above the expressway. And this is where Naseem tells Deputy Inspector O'Malley that Na wants to change the plan.
他打算去哪里？
Where is he planning to go?
（无法听清）
[INAUDIBLE]
没问题。
That's fine.
好的。
OK.
你——你知道，会有更多的警察，但好的。所以。
You're-- you know, there's going to be more cops, but OK.
有人需要告诉奥马利他们想去哪里。纳西姆转身寻找Na，Na已经走回人群中。
I'm just relaying information that I received.
我代表他说话。
I understand that. You gave me a route. You wouldn't give me a route. You never gave me the end of the route. We agreed upon the footbridge. I facilitated, but OK. So.
为了理清这一点，我们可以和组织者交谈。无论我们能做什么来让它成功——
Someone needs to tell O'Malley where they want to go. Naseem turns and looks for Na, who's walked back into the crowd.
我为你抓住他。
I'm speaking on his behalf.
好了，这又不是对峙。别想困住任何人。没人会戴上手铐。
So to make this cleared up, we could just speak to the organizer. And whatever we can do to make this work--
纳西姆！
I'm grabbing him for you.
纳西姆是Na的全名。这有点令人困惑。它和纳西姆（Naseem）很像，他的得力助手，这个家伙。
All right, this isn't a standoff. Don't try to trap anybody. No one's going to go in handcuffs.
纳西姆，我需要你。你需要表达——
Nasheem!
好的，好的。
Nasheem is Na's full name. It's a little confusing. It's very close to Naseem, his right hand man, this guy.
——你想要什么。退后。退后。给他点空间。
Nasheem, I need you. You need to articulate--
等等，听着。
All right, all right.
退后。
--what you like. Stand back. Stand back. Give him some space.
我们不是他们。我们很好。这很棒。我们很好。我们将继续保持良好。我知道你压力很大。你想去哪？你想去市中心？
Hold on, listen.
你说去市中心？
Stand back.
不。
We're not them. We're OK. This has been great. We're OK. We're going to keep being OK. I know you're under a lot of stress. Where do you want to go? You want to go downtown?
你可以去市中心，没问题。
You said to go downtown?
我是按照你想要的去。我在这里为你提供便利。你想要什么？
No.
我们市中心有人。没逮捕，没问题，好吗？
You can go downtown with no problem.
我们要去市中心。我们要去市中心。
I'm going by what you want. I'm here to facilitate for you. What do you want?
市中心完全没问题。你想去市中心，我们可以去市中心。
We've had people downtown. No arrests, no issues, all right?
我只是想说在我们在这里的时候。我得到的信息是从他那里来的，我得到后就传达给了你。
We're going downtown. We're going downtown.
没关系。听着，我们很好。
Downtown is totally fine. You want to go downtown, we could go downtown.
我是说，我只是想让你知道为什么。
And I just want to say while we're here. Information that I got was from him, and I relayed it you when I got it.
我从没承诺过我会——
It's OK. Listen, we're OK.
很紧张。最近几周有很多抗议活动，进展并不顺利。就在布鲁克林，警察殴打抗议者，开车撞向他们，人们向警察投掷火焰弹。这些事每个人都记在心里。
I mean, I just want you to know why.
所以——不——
I never promised that I would--
没关系。听着，我们没问题。一切都很好。
It's tense. There have been plenty of protests in recent weeks where things did not go well. Right here in Brooklyn, cops beating protesters, driving cars into them, people throwing firebombs at police. This stuff's on everyone's mind.
不，我想要透明度。
So there was-- no--
一切都很好。
It's OK. Listen, we're gravy. Everything's good.
我想要透明度。所以我只是在你在这里时保持透明。
No, I want transparency.
但你的人群开始躁动了。让他们动起来，好吗？他们有动力。让我们朝着积极的方向发展。
Everything is good.
好了，我们可以去市中心吗？
I want transparency. So I'm just being transparent while you're here.
好了？你想去市中心？好的，我们要去市中心。所以我们都要去市中心，对吧？我们要停止交通，对吧？好的。我们要打开这个。我们要走这条路。好了，我们很好？我们现在达成一致了吗？
But you're starting to get a restless crowd. Let's get them moving, all right? They have momentum. Let's take it in a positive direction.
是的。
All right, can we go downtown?
是吗？
All right? You want to go downtown? Yeah, we'll go downtown. So we're all going to go downtown, right? We're going to stop traffic, yeah? All right. We're going to open this up. We're going to go this way. All right, we're good? We're in agreement now?
一旦我们走出——
Yes.
顺便说一下，你好，维尼（Vinny）。你好吗？一旦我们离开第76分局，它就不在你的控制之下了。
Yeah?
不，我要和你走到巴克莱中心或者桥上或者——
So once we're out of--
哦，你是吗？
You're doing a good job. You're doing a really good job. All right? This is very successful. Let's keep it this way. What have you got?
——不管你要去哪儿，是的。
Once you-- hello, Vinny, by the way. How are you? Once we're out of the 76th, it's out of your control.
哦，好的，不错。
No, I am going to walk with you to Barclays or to the bridge or--
是的，是的。不，我们今天是个伙伴，好吗？这就是我说的。我们要一起做这件事。
Oh, you are?
重新开始。没有正义，什么的。没有正义！
--wherever you're going, yeah.
没有和平！
Oh, OK, nice.
慢慢地，慢慢地，请。缓慢地宣布。缓慢地呼吁。
Yeah, yeah. No, it's we're pals today, all right? That's what I'm saying. We're going to do this together.
警官推开其中一个金属大门，所以一次只有三四个人能走过去。Na回到人群中，拿着扩音器。纳西姆和我一起走在人群的前面。他转身对着路障分局侧的人们送了一些飞吻。
Start it back up. No justice, something. No justice!
你在给谁送飞吻？
No peace!
嗯？
Slowly, slowly, please. Give an announcement slowly. Call slowly.
你在给谁送飞吻？
The officers swing one of the metal gates open, so only three or four people can walk through at a time. Na is back in the crowd, with the bullhorn. Naseem and I walk through together, at the head of the crowd. He turns and blows some kisses towards people on the precinct side of the barrier.
我过去在这里工作，所以我是在向我的一个同事打招呼。
Who are you blowing kisses to?
你在哪工作？
Huh?
在第76分局。
Who are you blowing kisses to?
你在第76分局工作过？
I used to work here, so I'm saying hi to one of my co-workers.
是的。
Where did you work?
当我问起时，他对76分局的警官没什么坏话可说。他告诉我他正计划在执法部门从事某种职业。
In the 76th.
这是一次前往巴克莱中心的和平游行，距离一切开始的地方大约三英里。抗议一路吸引了越来越多的人。警方估计其高峰期有1200人。人群中的年轻女子走到Na身边，给了他她的号码，他礼貌地收下了。他们继续深入布鲁克林。在大军广场（Grand Army Plaza），Na站在喷泉墙上，回头看着等待听他说话的人海。
You worked at the 76th?
这太令人惊奇了。在这一点上我甚至不知道该说什么。
Yep.
谢谢。
When I ask about it, he doesn't have anything bad to say about the officers at the 76. And he tells me he's planning to have a career of some kind in law enforcement.
[欢呼]
It's a peaceful march to the Barclays Center, about three miles away from where it all began. The protest picks up more and more people along the way. The police estimated 1,200 people at its peak. The young woman in the crowd walks up to Na and gives him her number, which he takes politely. And they continue even deeper into Brooklyn. At Grand Army Plaza, Na stands up on the wall of a fountain and looks back at a sea of faces waiting to hear him speak.
我们做到了。我们做到了。我们做到了。
This is amazing. I don't even know what to say at this point.
有这么多人。想到这一切都始于小小的红钩，这太疯狂了。
Thank you.
[欢呼]
[CHEERING]
这给了我希望，你知道吗？看到这里所有这些人，所有这些盟友，所有这些年轻的黑人男子，所有这些年轻的黑人女子。让我们——我们能把拳头举起来吗，拜托？
We did it. We did it. We did it.
[欢呼]
There's just so many people. And to think it started all in little Red Hook, this is crazy.
我尽量不哭。我是黑人，我感到自豪！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
This gives me hope, you know? Seeing all these people here, all these allies, all these young black men, all these young black women. Let's just-- can we just put a fist up please?
几天后我在红钩的一个公园里见到了Na。当他走向我时，他正在和他的团队交谈，说也许接下来他会竞选某种民选职位。没什么太大的，只是地方性的。
[CHEERING]
昨天，我在家里，我就躺在床上。我想，哇。我真的他妈做到了。黑人，酷儿，牙齿坏了，有点胖——就像，妈的，我真的做到了。你知道我的意思吗？这感觉就像胜算对我不利。但我喜欢赢。我喜欢赢。
I'll try not to cry. I'm black and I'm proud!
达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）是我们节目的制片人之一。
[CHEERING]
第四幕，不要经过起点，不要收集200美元。有一段视频正在流传，我们很多人都看到了，我们认为在其中的作家金伯利·琼斯（Kimberly Jones）在给予背景和快速铺陈历史方面做得很好，以至于任何人都能理解。尽管这段视频在网上获得了很高的点击量，甚至在我们了解到约翰·奥利弗（John Oliver）上周结束他的HBO节目时播放了这段视频之后，我们仍然想在这里播放它。
I met up with Na a few days later in a park in Red Hook. When he walked up to me, he was talking to his team, saying maybe next he would run for some kind of elected position. Nothing too big, just something local.
金伯利·琼斯以谈论最近抗议活动中的抢劫者开始了这段视频。她说，人们对抢劫者说了所有这些负面的话，但没问为什么他们要抢劫。为了解释很多人的一种感觉，她开始讲述美国黑人的经济史，从奴隶制开始。
Yesterday, I was in my house, and I was just laying down on my bed. And I'm like, wow. I really fucking did that. Black, queer man, broken tooth, a little chubby-- like, shit, I really did that. You know what I mean? It just feels like the odds are stacked against me. And I like winning. I like winning.
我们绝不能忘记，经济是黑人被带到这个国家的原因。我们来南部做农业工作，在北部做纺织工作。你明白吗？这就是我们来做的事。
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our show.
现在，如果我现在决定我想和你玩大富翁，在400轮大富翁游戏中，我不让你有任何钱，我不让你在棋盘上有任何东西，我不让你有任何东西。然后我们又玩了50轮大富翁，你在玩那轮大富翁时获得和赚取的一切都被拿走了——那是塔尔萨（Tulsa）。那是罗斯伍德（Rosewood）。
Act Four, Do Not Pass Go, Do Not Collect $200. So there's this video making the rounds that a bunch of us saw, and we thought the writer who is in it, Kimberly Jones, did such a good job giving context and laying out a history quickly in a way that anybody can understand. That even though this video has gotten a lot of views online and even after we learned that John Oliver ended his HBO show last week with this video, we still wanted to play it here.
那些是我们建立黑人经济财富的地方，我们自给自足的地方，我们拥有商店的地方，我们拥有财产的地方，他们把它们烧成了平地。所以那是450年。所以400轮大富翁，你根本没机会玩。不仅你不能玩，你还得代表你正在与之对抗的那个人玩。你得玩，赚钱，为他们赚取财富，然后你得把它交给他们。
Kimberly Jones starts this video by talking about the looters in the recent protests. And she says, people say all these negative things about the looters, but don't ask why they're looting. And to explain a feeling that lots of people have, she launches into an economic history of black people in America, starting with slavery.
所以50年来，你终于得到了一点点，你被允许玩了。每次他们不喜欢你玩的方式，或者你赶上来了，或者你在做自给自足的事，他们就烧掉你的游戏。他们烧掉你的牌。他们烧掉你的大富翁钱。
We must never forget that economics was the reason that black people were brought to this country. We came to do the agricultural work in the south and the textile work in the north. Do you understand that? That's what we came to do.
然后，最后，在那之后，他们允许你玩，他们说，好吧，现在你赶上了。你怎么能赢？你怎么能赢？你不能赢。游戏是被操纵的。所以当他们说，为什么你烧毁了社区，为什么你烧毁了你自己的邻居，那不是我们的。我们什么都没有。我们什么都没有。
Now if I right now decided that I wanted to play Monopoly with you and for 400 rounds of playing Monopoly, I didn't allow you to have any money, I didn't allow you to have anything on the board, I didn't allow for you to have anything. And then we played another 50 rounds of Monopoly and everything that you gained and you earned while you were playing that round of Monopoly was taken from you-- that was Tulsa. That was Rosewood.
特雷弗·诺亚（Trevor Noah）昨晚说得太美了。我们所有人都有一个社会契约。如果你们偷窃或如果我偷窃，那么作为权威的人就会介入，他们会解决问题。但解决问题的人正在杀我们！所以社会契约被打破了。
Those are places where we built black economic wealth, where we were self-sufficient, where we owned our stores, where we owned our property, and they burned them to the ground. So that's 450 years. So for 400 rounds of Monopoly, you don't get to play at all. Not only do you not get to play, you have to play on the behalf of the person that you're playing against. You have to play and make money and earn wealth for them, and then you have to turn it over to them.
如果社会契约被打破了，为什么他妈的我还要在意烧毁该死的足球名人堂，烧毁该死的塔吉特（Target）？当你们在街上杀我们而且不在乎时，你们打破了契约！
So then for 50 years, you finally get a little bit, and you're allowed to play. And every time that they don't like the way that you're playing, or that you're catching up, or that you're doing something to be self-sufficient, they burn your game. They burn your cards. They burn your Monopoly money.
你们打破了契约，400年来，我们玩了你们的游戏，建立了你们的财富。当我们在塔尔萨靠自己从零开始再次建立财富时，你们打破了契约，你们向我们投掷炸弹。当我们在罗斯伍德建立它时，你们进来屠杀了我们。
And then, finally, at the release and the onset of that, they allow you to play and they say, OK, now you catch up. How can you win? How can you win? You can't win. The game is fixed. So when they say, why did you burn down the community, why did you burn down your own neighborhood, it's not ours. We don't own anything. We don't own anything.
你们打破了契约，所以去他妈的塔吉特。去他妈的名人堂。据我所知，他们可以把这个婊子烧成平地。那仍然不够。他们很幸运，黑人寻找的是平等，而不是复仇。
Trevor Noah said it so beautifully last night. There's a social contract that we all have. That if you steal or if I steal, then the person who is the authority comes in and they fix the situation. But the person who fixes the situation is killing us! So the social contract is broken.
金伯利·琼斯，她是一位作家，一本青年小说的作者。她的网站是KimJonesWrites.com。
And if the social contract is broken, why the fuck do I give a shit about burning the fucking Football Hall of Fame, about burning a fucking Target? You broke the contract when you killed us in the streets and didn't give a fuck!
[音乐 - Run The Jewels的《Walking in the Snow》]
You broke the contract, and for 400 years, we played your game and built your wealth. You broke the contract when we built our wealth again on our own by our bootstraps in Tulsa, and you dropped bombs on us. When we built it in Rosewood, and you came in and you slaughtered us.
我们的节目今天由纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）和比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）制作。制作今天节目的人包括伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stow Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katharine Rae Mondo）、本·费兰（Ben Phelan）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）。
You broke the contract, so fuck your Target. Fuck your Hall of Fame. Far as I'm concerned, they could burn this bitch to the ground. And it still wouldn't be enough. And they are lucky that what black people are looking for is equality and not revenge.
我们的管理编辑是戴安·吴（Diane Wu）和萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sara Abdurrahman）。我们的执行编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。感谢埃里克·史蒂文斯（Eric Stevens）以及芒果先生和梦之队Felix的工作人员。今天节目网站上的艺术作品来自阿德里安·布兰登（Adrian Brandon）。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
Kimberly Jones, she's a writer, author of a young adult novel. Her website is KimJonesWrites.com.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。你知道，他选择了一种有趣的方式来向员工宣布我们设备预算的一些削减。
[MUSIC - "WALKING IN THE SNOW" BY RUN THE JEWELS]
我需要每个人跟着我重复。一个麦克风。
Our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman and Bim Adewunmi. The people who made today's show include Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Lina Misitzis, Stow Nelson, Katharine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Julie Whitaker.
一个麦克风。
Our managing editors are Diane Wu and Sara Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Thanks today to Eric Stevens and the staff of Mr. Mango and Dream Team Felix. The art on our website for today's show is by Adrian Brandon. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he chose a funny way to announce to the staff some cutbacks in our equipment budget.
一个麦克风。
I need everybody to repeat after me. One mic.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
One mic.
一个麦克风。
一支麦克风。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，我们将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。